.
* Hupen *
Hoi.
Schau, wer kommt.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
Auch alle Kinder.
Achtung!
Schaut, hallo. Hoi.
* Eva murmelt. *
Hallo, Kinder.
(Theresa) Ab in den Pool.
- Ist doch super.
Boah, super Arschbombe.
Marina Marrer und Mike Hostettler
eröffnen ihren Waffelshop in Tampa.
Es ist noch nicht real für mich.
Keine Ahnung,
ich finde es sehr geil.
You can have the Waffle with:
Hershey's, Reese's, Oreos, Twix,
Snickers, KitKat, Gummy Bears,
M&M's, Kinder Bueno, Kinder Riegel,
Raffaello, Ferrero Rocher.
Die Begeisterung ist gross,
die Arbeitstage sind lang:
14 Std. pro Tag,
sieben Tage die Woche sind die Regel.
Thank you, guys. See you.
- Bye, thank you so much.
Im Moment heisst es arbeiten,
arbeiten und noch mal arbeiten.
Unser grösstes Problem ist es,
zuverlässige Mitarbeiter zu finden.
Im Moment
ist es irgendwie ein Stress.
Viel Arbeit auch in Frankreich
auf dem riesigen Hof
der Bauernfamilie Wieser:
Die Mähsaison ist angebrochen.
Söhnchen Gian ist oft bei Papa.
Wegen Corona hat der Achtjährige
vorgezogene Ferien.
Wir sind ein Dreamteam.
Er ist der Traum und ich das Team.
Du musst es hinten hochheben.
Nicht vorne rumschrauben.
Es ist recht schwer hier vorne.
Ein Leben in Bella Italia.
Eva Dudle und Philippe Sguaitamatti
haben in der Toskana
ein Agriturismo übernommen -
die italienische Variante
von Ferien auf dem Bauernhof.
Ist gut?
-Gut.
Einst waren die beiden
ein Liebespaar,
nun sind sie Geschäftspartner.
Wir könnten
eine Montagefirma eröffnen.
Nicht mehr in diesem Leben.
Im nächsten dann.
Die Finanzierung
unerwarteter Ausgaben
entzweit die beiden immer mehr.
Philippe möchte
einen Geschäftskredit aufnehmen,
Eva will lieber in kleinen Schritten
eigenes Geld investieren.
Jetzt müssen wir einen Brunnen
für eigenes Wasser bauen.
Da ich kein Freund der Banken bin,
ist es für mich stressig,
wenn es darum geht,
einen Kredit aufzunehmen.
Damit habe ich ein Problem.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Vögel rufen. *
Schon in den frühen Morgenstunden
ist es heiss.
Der Ferragosto - Italiens
Sommerferien sind angebrochen.
Schön, das ist ...
Ich finde das so lustig am Sonntag.
Jetzt kommen noch die Biker.
Der Gästebetrieb des Agriturismo
ist überraschend schnell angelaufen.
Oh, allora.
Veramente bene.
Ciao, grazie.
Ciao, amore.
Die ersten Gäste, die wieder gehen,
sind Gott sei Dank zufrieden.
Kaum haben die Italienerinnen
das Tor passiert,
kommt die nächste Anfrage.
* Klingelton *
Pronto?
Si, ciao Luca.
Senti.
Unglaublich.
Ich finde es schön, irgendwie kommt
es ins Rollen, das finde ich super.
Echt.
Wenn nur dieser schwelende Konflikt
nicht wäre.
Die beiden sind sich nicht einig
über Ausrichtung und Finanzierung
des Betriebes.
Sicher ist:
Sie müssen mehr Land urbar machen,
und auch das wird kosten.
Ackerbau Ð
eine komplett neue Aufgabe für Eva.
Ich wurde ein Leben lang
mit neuen Sachen konfrontiert,
die ich nicht kannte.
Und ...
Das ist eine Herausforderung,
aber auch spannend.
Mal schauen, ob ich das auch kann.
Oder muss ich nach ein paar Jahren
sagen, dass ich es nicht schaffe?
Ich bin mir sicher,
dass ich im Leben bin,
um zu arbeiten und zu lernen.
Das ist der Motor meines Lebens,
das habe ich bisher so gelebt.
Ich fange jetzt
nichts Neues mehr an,
eigentlich hat es sich so bewährt.
Trotz Pensionsalter:
Einfach nichts tun
wird es für Eva wohl nie geben.
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Tampa -
das Grand Plaza Shopping Center.
Hier ist der Waffelshop
der Florida-Auswanderer.
Monatelang hatten Marina und Mike
Seite an Seite gearbeitet.
Mit Erfolg:
Das Geschäft boomt.
Doch nun,
von einem Tag auf den anderen,
steht Marina allein im Geschäft.
Seit Mike weg ist ...
... bin ich irgendwie ...
Es muss alles noch schneller gehen
als zu zweit.
100 Std. in der Woche ohne
einen einzigen freien Tag schuften,
und dies während Monaten.
Mike hatte einen Zusammenbruch.
Wie aus dem Nichts
hatte er eines Tages Panikattacken
und fühlte sich schwach.
"Stopp!" sagte der Arzt.
Dies seien
erste Anzeichen eines Burnouts.
Er verordnete ihm Ruhe
und Medikamente.
Seit Tagen ist er nun daheim.
Vor 14 Tagen
sagte mein Körper im Laden:
"Stopp, zu viel des Guten."
Mein Blutdruck stieg massiv
und sank nicht mehr.
Ich musste bzw. durfte mir
Ruhe gönnen.
Wir haben es so verknüpft, dass ich
14 Tage zu Hause bleibe und packe.
Schachteln füllen
und immer wieder eine Pause einlegen,
das geht.
Denn bald schon
werden die beiden auch noch umziehen.
Im Waffelshop trägt Marina
die Verantwortung nun allein.
Zuverlässiges Personal zu finden
ist nach wie vor schwierig.
Maddie ist Studentin.
Sie unterstützt Marina,
so oft sie kann.
Noch ist völlig unklar,
wie lange Mike ausfallen wird.
Letzte Woche haben wir es probiert,
da kam er mit
und half mir am Morgen vorbereiten.
Für mich war das eine Erleichterung.
Aber es ging dann nicht gut.
Trotzdem: Ich weiss, er ist hier,
er würde mir helfen,
aber mit gewissen Sachen
möchte ich ihn gar nicht belasten.
Jetzt ist wichtig,
dass er zur Ruhe kommt.
Can I call you back later?
Sorry, I'm pretty busy.
Or can you send me an e-mail?
Ihr Partner fehlt einfach überall.
Einkaufen gehen ...
... alles alleine schleppen.
Nachts, wenn es dunkel ist,
den Laden schliessen
mit dem Geld ...
Als er hier war,
gab er mir eine gewisse Sicherheit.
Er gibt sein Bestes.
Mir fehlt einfach
eine gewisse Unterstützung.
Ich muss nach uns beiden schauen -
nebst dem Laden
und den Mitarbeitern.
Ja.
* Akkordeonversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
In Frankreich gehören die Wiesers
zu den grössten Milchproduzenten
der Gegend.
Bonjour. Salut.
Die Molkerei Beillevaire in Machecoul
ist Abnehmer ihrer Milch.
Tu veux un quart?
S'il vous plaît.
Voilà.
Also die Joghurts
sind wirklich der Hammer.
In der Schweiz
habe ich keinen Joghurt gegessen,
nur den stichfesten Schokoladen-
joghurt, der war der einzige,
den ich gegessen habe,
und hier esse ich fast alle.
T'en veux combien?
Täglich liefern die Wiesers
6'000 l Milch nach Machecoul.
Mindestens einmal in der Woche
kauft Aleksandra hier ein.
Als Zulieferin hat sie 20 % Rabatt.
Hier wird aus unserer Milch
die Butter hergestellt.
Es wird alles von Hand gemacht,
das ist mega cool.
In einem Drittel aller Produkte hier
steckt die Milch
der Schweizer Auswanderer.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Zurück zum Hof Les Aubiers.
Wiesers füttern die Tiere
hauptsächlich mit Mais und Gras.
Angestellte, Hilfskräfte und Bauern
aus der Gegend
unterstützen Sandro Wieser.
In den Sommermonaten
macht er vier Schnitte.
Von der landwirtschaftlichen
Kooperative
hat er einen Häcksler zugemietet.
Doch plötzlich steht alles still.
Eine Panne oder mehrere,
das kann es geben.
Ich weiss nicht, was los ist.
Man kann ihn ja abstellen.
Was machst du jetzt?
Repariere lieber den Häcksler,
wenn du zu viel Energie hast.
Hast du den Schraubenschlüssel
dabei?-Nein.
Das Werkzeugset?
- Nein, das ist zu Hause.
Aussteigen.
Nichts geht mehr.
Der kaputte Häcksler
blockiert die Arbeit
von vier Fahrern samt Traktoren.
* Verspielte Akkordeonklänge *
* Hoher Hupton *
Wieser, der Cheftechniker:
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Dass Sandro ratlos ist,
kommt selten vor.
Er ist einer, der sich eigentlich
immer irgendwie zu helfen weiss.
Auch Sandros Mitarbeiter
wissen nicht weiter.
Ein Ersatz muss her -
schnellstmöglich.
D.h., es wird auch heute
wieder Mitternacht.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie die Abrechnung aussieht.
Man muss Leute organisieren,
die dann stundenlang rumstehen
und kosten.
* Drollige Klänge *
Hundstage in der Toskana.
Es ist stickig heiss.
Boah.
Ein laues Lüftchen
wird zum Stürmchen -
und gibt Hoffnung.
Wohin ziehen die Wolken?
Jetzt sieht es nach Gewitter aus.
Trotz einiger schwerer Tropfen:
Fehlalarm.
Wieder kein Gewitter, wieder kein
Regen und dies seit Wochen schon.
Drückend wie das Wetter ist auch
die Stimmung bei den Zürchern.
Entschuldigung.
- Ja, bitte.
Einen Besen
brauchen wir noch in den Häusern.
Philippe und Eva müssen
grundlegende Entscheide fällen.
Ein Konsens scheint in weiter Ferne.
Ein Eklat gar unabwendbar.
Doch heute will Eva
keine Probleme wälzen.
Sie ist voller Vorfreude:
Eine Tochter
reist mit den Enkelkindern an.
Ihre Familie war ein wichtiger Grund
für den Kauf des Gutes.
Es soll auch ein Hort
für ihre Liebsten werden.
Das sind vergangene Muttergefühle.
Nie sterbende Muttergefühle.
Das ist man ein Leben lang,
Mutter ist man immer.
Das kann man nicht abgeben.
Man kann sich nicht pensionieren
lassen, das geht nicht.
Das ist ein Job fürs Leben.
* Hupen *
Doch, das ist sie. Komm zu mir!
Und schon sind sie da.
Hoi.
Schau, wer kommt.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
Auch alle Kinder.
Achtung!
Schaut, hallo. Hoi.
* Eva murmelt. *
Das hast du gut gemacht.
Ihr seid so lange gefahren.
Jennele?
Eva ist eine richtige Clanchefin.
Sie hat vier Töchter, drei Söhne
und acht Enkelkinder.
Jetzt aber.
- Ab in den Pool.
Das ist doch super.
Wunderbar.
Das Herz ist offen, es fliesst.
Es ist mega gut.
So vieles gibt es für die Enkel zu
entdecken im Agriturismo der Nonna.
Volle Pulle.
Jetzt mit Schmackes.
Eins, zwei, Gantenbein.
Boah, super Arschbombe. Sehr gut.
Hast du neue bekommen?
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Umzugstermin in Tampa.
Für Mike
ein besonders wichtiger Moment.
Er verspricht sich viel
von diesem Umzug.
Irgendwie
ist es befreiend für mein Herz.
Ich kann nicht sagen, warum,
aber es ist ...
Als ob Druck von mir weicht.
Damit musst du vorsichtig sein,
Kamerad.
Das ist ein wertvolles Stück:
der Korpus
mit seinen Tätowier-Utensilien,
ein Abschiedsgeschenk
von Schweizer Freunden.
Mike hofft, irgendwann
wieder tätowieren zu können.
Yes, Sir.
Doch das ist im Moment kein Thema.
Der Berner
fühlt sich noch nicht gesund
und braucht immer wieder
einen Moment Ruhe.
Bye-bye Cottontail Place,
ein neues Kapitel der Florida-
Auswanderer kann beginnen.
Und hopp, yes!
Souverän.
Auf nach Tarpon Springs.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Das neue Daheim liegt weiter nördlich
und ist ein Vorort von Tampa.
Ein kleiner Wald
liegt direkt vor ihrer Haustüre.
Hier ist alles noch ein wenig wilder.
Mehr von der Natur umgeben,
darauf freuen sich alle drei.
Freunde haben ihnen
das Haus vermittelt.
Herfahren, aussteigen
und heimkommen.
Ich weiss nicht warum, es passt.
Ich fühle mich wohl,
es ist komplett was anderes,
man hat die Natur,
Freunde,
geniale Nachbarn, auch hier.
Es ist gross, heller,
es ist nicht so drückend.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Du strangulierst dich!
- They play.
Kaum eingezogen,
treffen sie bereits Nachbarn.
We'll have to go to ...
You guys bake waffles?
- Yes, waffles.
In Frankreich ging es schneller
als befürchtet:
Nach 30 Min. schon stand
ein Ersatzhäcksler auf dem Feld.
Es dauert nicht bis Mitternacht,
aber dunkel ist es allemal,
bis die Maschinen
endlich stillstehen.
Sandro Wieser ist geschafft.
Noch mehr aber ist er stolz.
54 ha ...
Das ist genau dreimal
der Betrieb in der Schweiz.
Ja, dreimal.
Schön, wie sie mitmachen.
Sie sind nicht daran gewöhnt,
in diesen Dimensionen
Gras zu silieren.
Gras ist für sie ...
... ein notwendiges Übel.
Sie sind auf Mais festgefahren.
Der Mais gibt weniger Arbeit.
Für den Schweizer Bauern
ist es wichtig,
seinen Tieren genügend Gras
verfüttern zu können.
Denn Gras ist proteinhaltiger
als Mais.
Jetzt trinken wir zuerst
einen Aperitif.
Wir sind ja in Frankreich.
Oui.
Die Kühe haben auch einen Aperitif.
In der Schweiz hatte Sandro
gut 300 t Gras siliert.
Hier sind es fünfmal so viele.
Nebst 4'000 t Mais.
Bekommen sie Geld?
Ja, ja,
die machen gar nichts gratis.
Oui.
* Unverständliches Gespräch
auf Französisch *
Directe? On roule petit peu après.
Non, non, avant ...
Cin. Santé.
- Prost. Cin.
Die Nacht ist kurz.
Les Aubiers
ist kein kleiner Bauernhof,
wie ihn die Wiesers
in der Schweiz hatten,
sondern ein grosses Unternehmen.
Vor Kurzem haben die Wiesers
eine zusätzliche Tierwohlkontrolle
bestanden.
Die charte du bien-être animal
ist ein Label,
das die Molkerei
von den Bauern verlangt.
Ja.
200 Kühe,
total sind es 460 Tiere im Betrieb,
das ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Aber Massentierhaltung
fängt bei der Haltung an.
Es gibt leider auch Beispiele,
wo 20 Kühe schlecht gehalten werden.
Es ist eine Frage
der Qualität der Haltung,
der Einstellung,
die man gegenüber den Tieren hat.
Das ist unsere Existenzgrundlage.
Jeder Mensch geht doch sorgfältig
mit seiner Existenzgrundlage um.
Um den Nachwuchs ihrer Tiere
kümmert sich Aleksandra.
Schau mal, wer da ist.
Fast jeden zweiten Tag kommt
auf Les Aubiers ein Junges zur Welt.
Momentan sind es 60 Kälber.
Jedes bekommt 6 l Milch am Tag
gefüttert.
Das macht die Kleinen stark,
und für Aleksandra gibt's Muskeln.
Das braucht extrem viel Kraft,
aber nicht mehr lange.
Ich habe ein Taxi-Lait gekauft.
Damit kann man fahren.
Mega cool.
So ist arbeiten recht uncool.
Noch schleppt sie
die schweren Kannen selber -
das Taxi-Lait hat sie erst bestellt.
Mit diesem elektrischen Milchwagen
wird die Fütterung der Kälber
einfacher werden.
Wen haben wir denn da?
Zafira und Sydney.
Das Handling
ist anders mit 200 Kühen.
Man kann sie nicht verhätscheln
und stundenlang
im Stall Kühe streicheln,
das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber die Versorgung
ist genau gleich.
Ob man 50 oder 200 Kühe füttert.
Man sollte so wenig Fehler
wie möglich machen.
Auch wirtschaftlich -
ich kenne die Zahlen.
Ich weiss genau, wie viel Kosten
das Futter verursacht.
Wenn ich das nicht täglich weiss,
dann habe ich verloren.
Bauer Wieser ist ein nüchterner
Unternehmer und Rechner.
Doch Zahlen, Kosten, Marge
hin oder her ...
Salut, Schätzchen.
Aleksandra nimmt sich trotzdem Zeit
zum Verhätscheln.
Besonders mit den Rindern, die sie
aus der Schweiz mitgenommen haben.
Tarpon Springs in Tampa:
der neue Wohnsitz
der Florida-Auswanderer.
Ihr Zuhause liegt gut
30 Min. entfernt von ihrem Geschäft.
Tschau.
- Melde dich. Bye.
Ein Klacks für US-Verhältnisse.
Djuna.
Noch immer bleibt Mike daheim, noch
immer fühlt er sich nicht kräftig.
Weder seelisch noch körperlich.
Ihn plagen Schwindel
und Kopfschmerzen
und sein Nacken ist so verspannt,
dass ihm das Atmen
immer wieder Mühe bereitet.
Wie lange geht das noch?
Wie lange muss Marina
den Waffelladen alleine managen?
Auch sie
hat erste Ermüdungserscheinungen.
Zeitweise mag ich nicht mehr.
Wir haben uns einige Male
die Frage gestellt, wie weiter.
Wenn dann auch ich nicht mehr mag,
wer macht es dann?
Das ist dann ...
Wenn wir das hier aufgeben müssen,
haben wir nichts mehr.
Ja.
Es gibt nur eines: Durchbeissen
und hoffen, dass es klappt.
Seit gut einem Jahr
ist die ehemalige Productmanagerin
eigenständige Unternehmerin.
Und als solche
hat sie zusammen mit Partner Mike
eine Entscheidung getroffen.
Wir haben gestern entschieden,
dass wir mittwochs schliessen.
Wir haben das
mit dem Franchisegeber besprochen.
Wir müssen es mit ihm absprechen.
Sie zeigten extrem viel Verständnis.
Der Franchisegeber sagte,
dass wir an diesem Tag
das Handy ausschalten sollen.
Wir müssen uns selbst
an der Nase nehmen.
Aber es ist unser Business.
Nach monatelangem Schuften endlich
ein fixer, gemeinsamer freier Tag.
* Gelassene Gitarrenklänge *
Schon in den frühen Morgenstunden
herrscht reger Betrieb
im Agriturismo.
Klein und Gross
sind begeistert vom Gut.
Und helfen mit, es herzurichten.
Eva ist froh um die Unterstützung.
Bald schon kommen weitere Gäste an.
Noch ist nicht alles perfekt,
und die Auswanderer haben
schliesslich hohe Ansprüche
an die eigene Gastfreundschaft.
Jetzt müssen wir
das Zimmer vorbereiten
für das Ehepaar, das heute kommt.
Theresa montiert die Vorhänge.
Ich muss etwas suchen,
ich habe ein Rechaud,
damit sie Kaffee machen können.
Das muss man noch installieren,
aber das ist keine Hexerei.
Ich brauche einen neuen Stecker.
Kann ich dir helfen, Thes?
Geht es?
Willst du die Bohrmaschine?
Das wäre vielleicht nicht schlecht.
- Also, komm.
Eva hatte schon früh
in Liegenschaften investiert.
Sieben Häuser
hat sie in der Schweiz umgebaut.
Wir sind auf Baustellen
gross geworden.
Die Arbeiter gingen ein und aus
und plauderten mit uns.
Es ist einfach super
mit meinen Töchtern.
Auch meine Söhne sind so.
Man arbeitet Hand in Hand.
Man muss nicht reden, man arbeitet.
Die Frauen haben übernommen.
Das sollte gehen.
Sonst musst du daneben
ein Streichholz reinstecken.
Nimm mal diesen hier.
Dabei war es eigentlich Philippe,
der tags zuvor begonnen hatte,
die Vorhangstange zu montieren.
Es ist nicht einfach, Teil dieses
eingeschworenen Bauteams zu werden.
Geht es?
- Selbstverständlich.
Philippe wollte mit Arbeitern
die Pfosten um den Pool setzen,
doch das hat nicht geklappt.
Er kann es nicht lassen,
bei den Frauen vorbeizuschauen.
Ich verstehe einfach eines nicht:
Warum kann ich das jetzt nicht
machen, sondern jemand anders?
Du sagtest, du hättest ...
- Was du immer interpretierst!
Gut, Thesi, wir machen einen Abflug.
Du hast gestern Abend gesagt,
du hättest heute keine Zeit,
du seist absorbiert.
Ja, wegen der Pfosten.
Aber dort ist nichts passiert.
Das kann ich auch nicht ändern.
- Ich auch nicht.
Verdammt noch mal!
- Dann mach du es.- Wir gehen.
Ja, ja.
Nachdem ...
Das Gewitter ist da:
zu viele Missverständnisse
und latente Unstimmigkeiten.
Wir haben schon mega viel Erde
rausgeschaufelt.
Ach, echt.
Wenn sie das Gefühl hat,
sie könne alles allein stemmen,
soll sie das machen.
Sie kann ihre Kinder einspannen,
sie kann alles machen:
Es ist mir egal.
Langsam ...
... nervt mich das derartig.
Ihr seht, dass es mir nicht guttut.
Dann soll sie ihre Kinder
runterbringen.
Das hat auch der Buchhalter
zu ihr gesagt:
Man muss sich entscheiden,
ob man eine Kolonie
für die Kinder machen will,
oder ob man ...
... ein Unternehmen haben will ...
... das etwas erwirtschaftet
oder sonst etwas Schönes macht.
Ich meine ...
Im Grunde genommen ist es mir wurst.
Ich habe mir meine Pension
ein bisschen anders vorgestellt.
Die Situation zwischen den beiden
ist komplett verfahren.
Ich weiss einfach nicht,
ob wir beide
die Richtigen dafür sind.
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Weil wir in vielen Dingen
nicht die gleiche Sprache sprechen.
Es beginnt bei Ansichten
über Corona, Politik usw.
Einfach, wirklich ...
Es gibt ganz wenige Dinge, bei denen
wir wirklich einer Meinung sind.
Aber aus Fehlern lernt man.
Dann muss man die Fehler
so ausbügeln,
damit es weitergehen kann.
Du bist ein Feiner.
Mit viel Mut und Herzblut
sind die beiden Zürcher
das Projekt angegangen.
Beide hängen daran,
wollen es weiterziehen.
Doch werden sie es
gemeinsam schaffen?
In Frankreich bei den Wiesers
gibt es heute Tiramisu,
das Lieblingsdessert
von Gians Schwester Joana.
Die Coronapandemie hatte das Reisen
nach Frankreich verunmöglicht.
Nach fünf langen Monaten
kommt Joana endlich zu Besuch.
Es war schon die Idee, dass sie
ein- oder zweimal im Monat kommen.
Die Flüge kosten ja nichts.
Es war anders gedacht, aber eben.
Jetzt ist es halt so.
Die Freude ist umso grösser,
wenn sie gleich da ist.
Diese Tage werden wir geniessen.
* Melancholische Akkordeonklänge *
Kaum war die Schweiz nicht mehr
auf der Risikoliste der Franzosen,
kaufte Sandro der Tochter
ein Flugticket.
(Tränenerstickt) Hoi, Mami.
- Hoi.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Ich habe einfach Ohrendruck.
- Dann musst du zudrücken.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut.
Aber ich war nervös,
das Fliegen macht mir etwas Angst.
Ich habe es gut gemeistert und freue
mich, den Rest der Familie zu sehen.
Die hatten Stress im Flieger.
Okay. Hast du nichts gegessen?
Doch, aber es waren
zwei so kleine Laugenbrötchen.
Ah, hast du das
für 5.50 Fr. genommen?
Im Flugzeug
haben sie Englisch mit mir geredet.
Ich habe nicht Französisch geredet.
Ich kann es ja nicht.
- Du kannst es schon.
Du musst dich nur trauen
und einfach reden.- Nein.
Mach es wie ich.
Patrice schaut mich an und sagt:
Dann sage ich: "Alors."
Dann versteht er, was ich meine,
und ich frage ihn,
wie man es richtig sagt.
Er sagt es mir dann.
Aleksandra ist anpassungsfähig.
Das und die Lust, sich
auf eine neue Lebensart einzulassen,
kommen ihr als Auswanderin
nun zugute.
Wir Schweizer müssen hier lernen,
also Sandro und ich,
einfach mal piano ...
Wir sind nicht mehr in der Schweiz.
Nicht mehr hopp, hopp und zack, zack
und am besten 24 Std. am Tag.
Sie sind Geniesser,
sie geniessen das Leben.
Das ist so schön bei den Franzosen.
Diese Spontanität.
Auf einmal
stehen die Nachbarn im Garten,
trinken ein Bier
und haben es lustig.
Ja.
Dort wohnt der grösste Teil
der Nachbarn.
So.
Hoppla.
* Sehnsüchtige Akkordeonklänge *
Hoi.
- Hallo, Kind.
Bist du aus dem Flieger gefallen?
Zehn Tage
bleibt die 20-jährige Joana.
Gian wird jeden Moment mit ihr
geniessen.
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
In Tampa hat Mike
einen wichtigen Termin -
eine Behandlung beim Chiropraktiker.
Kann der Therapeut
Mikes körperliches Leiden lindern?
* Mike seufzt. *
Wie Tag und Nacht.
Hier.
Stressbedingt.
Von der Bewegung her.
Keinen Sport mehr gemacht.
Ich gehe nächste Woche
Dienstag und Mittwoch nochmals.
Dann sollte ich nächste Woche
wieder slowly arbeiten können.
Er kann sicher damit helfen,
dass es hier lockerer wird.
Dass wir den Stress in unserem Leben
reduzieren müssen, wissen wir auch.
Allein die Behandlung durch einen
Chiropraktiker ist nicht die Lösung.
Nein!
Wir müssen unser ganzes Leben
umkrempeln.- Genau.
Die beiden müssen wohl
grundlegend etwas ändern.
Dem geschäftigen Alltag
ein bisschen Freizeit abtrotzen
und sich eine Pause gönnen,
das ist zumindest ein Anfang.
Hast du kein Spray?
- Doch.
Fuck.
- Ja.
Mich fressen sie auch schon.
Die Tampa Bay Area
ist eine Gegend mit Süsswasserseen
und vielen romantischen Plätzchen.
Ich habe Schiss,
dass plötzlich ein Alligator kommt.
Es ist so still.
(Flüsternd) Bis der Alligator kommt.
- Der kommt nicht.
Ich stinke zu sehr.
Sie haben gesagt,
man müsse vorsichtig sein,
sie seien unter dem Steg.
- Ja, ja.
Dort ist ein Ast.
- Das ist kein Ast ...
* Entferntes Bellen *
Schau, jetzt ist der Ast weg.
- Er ist weg.
Doch geniessen und abschalten
ist einfacher gesagt als getan.
Ich nehme mir vor ...
Wir brauchen wieder mehr Zeit
für uns, auch für die Beziehung.
Bewusster Leben.
Aber das klingt alles so gut.
Schlussendlich
hat man sich entschieden,
ein eigenes Business zu eröffnen.
Wenn man nicht hart arbeitet,
hat man auch keinen Erfolg.
Oh. Fuck.
Keine Pause für Marina und Mike.
In der nächsten Folge sind sie zu
einem Dessert-Festival eingeladen.
Es wäre cool, wenn wir gewinnen
würden, das gibt Promotion.
Aber kurz vor der Veranstaltung
wird Marina krank.
Mike muss 1'000 Waffelherzen
alleine backen.
Was ist es denn?
Aber noch keine Lungenentzündung?
Im Moment
blockiert eine Person alles.
In der Toskana gehen sich Philippe
und Eva zunehmend aus dem Weg.
Das Projekt kommt zum Stillstand.
Eva entscheidet sich,
das Agriturismo zu verkaufen.
Zuerst dachte ich,
wir könnten das als Kollegen machen.
Dann merkte ich:
Das funktioniert nicht.
Hier kannst du das Meer hören.
Für Ausflüge an den Strand
bleibt Wiesers wenig Zeit.
Ich habe nicht viel
von Frankreich gesehen.
Sie investieren viel Zeit,
Geld und in die Technik ihres Hofes.
Das ist mein
günstigster Mitarbeiter.
Nicht immer
zur Freude der Angestellten.
Ich muss ihre Abläufe aufbrechen,
damit wir wieder
einen Schritt nach vorne kommen.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt nu uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022
# Uf u dervo, yeah.